On Wednesday,
the 31st of January at 7:30 PM,
I'm going to be speaking about my new
book and its genesis at the lovely
orpheum theater in Los Angeles,
and so I'd like to invite you to attend.
I'll talk for about an hour and a half
or so perhaps to take questions from the
audience and then sign and dedicate
books and so if you'd be interested in
hearing about 12 rules for life and
about how it came about and what it's
about and why,
then please come to the theater and
we'll have a fine time.
So looking forward to seeing you there.
12 rules for life,
how to live properly in the face of
vulnerability,
tragedy,
and malevolence.
One of the propositions in 12 rules for
life is that life existence is usefully
characterized as an interplant order and
chaos or unknown unknown.
You're always striving to balance those
two.
If if,
if what you,
what you're doing is too familiar your
board and if what you're doing is to
unfamiliar,
then you're anxious and what you want to
do is find the harmonious line between
those two and that signified by leaning.
If you can get those two things right,
then you can have your cake and eat it
too.
I hope people can take away the idea
that there is a motive being in the face
of the vulnerability and tragedy of life
that is noble and powerful and capable
of sustaining them through the worst
possible times without becoming corrupt
and bitter.